[Música]
algunos de los presentes no ha traído
hoy el móvil
o mejor aún
en las últimas 24 horas alguno de los
que está aquí no ha utilizado un móvil
pues fíjense lo que ocurriría si la
sociedad actual no fuera capaz de
utilizar y medir el tiempo con precisión
estos dispositivos
tan indiscutiblemente imprescindible en
nuestras vidas resultaría que serían
artilugios que no tendrían ningún valor
destinados a convertirse en pura
chatarra
incluso
si queremos utilizarlo con utilidad es
mucho más simples como dispositivos
digitales
por ejemplo como una cámara de fotos o
se me ocurre
como una agenda digital
resulta que necesitan una señal de reloj
para que se pueda sincronizar todas las
operaciones que tienen lugar entre sus
componentes sin esa señal del reloj
no habría dispositivo que valiera y esto
es así algo a lo que estamos tan
habituados habitualmente
no valdría absolutamente para nada si no
fuera por el hecho de que somos capaces
de medir con precisión y objetividad el
tiempo
y el interés por medir y comprender el
tiempo nos acompaña desde hace muchísimo
tiempo al hombre y si efectivamente el
hombre trato de tener y se aventuró a
tener métodos para determinar
rápidamente las obras o las fechas
no ocurría lo mismo con la comprensión
del tiempo comprender el tiempo y su
naturaleza es algo bastante más reciente
y yo diría que no hemos terminado de
tener una idea clara de lo que
representa el tiempo
sabemos de la existencia del tiempo
porque lo percibimos
y a decir verdad no percibimos el tiempo
percibimos los eventos percibimos los
acontecimientos y percibimos como estos
van cambiando y precisamente en ese
cambio es en donde apreciamos realmente
que el tiempo transcurre
por tanto el tiempo es subjetivo el
tiempo depende de cada individuo y
depende de sus circunstancias
imaginen por un momento estoy seguro de
que todos los que están aquí presentes
se han encontrado con situaciones muy
concretas situaciones ante eventos
inesperados situaciones peligrosas y
verdad que han tenido toda la sensación
de que el tiempo se congelaba como si
fuera cámara lenta
algo parecido a lo que ocurre cuando el
tiempo transcurre
sin nada importante que ocurre en
nuestras vidas
o cuando lo que ocurre son pocas cosas
realmente pasa el tiempo como muy lento
y viceversa
y en el caso contrario tenemos
precisamente la situación
en la que estando en una situación
divertida entretenida
emocionante novedosa resulta que tenemos
la sensación de que el tiempo se nos va
que pena que se nos está acabando el
tiempo y que aquello va a acabar
pues bien precisamente por eso es por lo
que el hombre ha tenido que buscar a lo
largo de la historia maneras de
controlar ese tiempo de manera objetiva
para que no dependa de esa imperfección
de sus sentidos
y de esta manera
desde que las sociedades abandonan
la caza y la recolección para dedicarse
a la agricultura ya la ganadería
tenemos sociedades en las cuales empieza
a interesar medir el tiempo de manera
objetiva esto ocurre en la época del
neolítico siete mil quinientos años
antes de cristo
y resulta que en aquella era importante
predecir la llegada de las diferentes
estaciones del año para poder planificar
los cultivos las cosechas
y esto como lo hacían aquellos hombres
pues lógicamente se las ingeniaban para
hacerlo con cosas tan simples como
estacas de madera clavadas en el suelo y
podían apreciar a partir de la longitud
de las sombras realmente cuando iba a
llegar el momento preciso para hacer el
cultivo o la cosecha que antes
mencionada
en cuanto a la organización de las horas
dentro del día la cosa es más compleja
porque no existen procesos
que se presenta en la naturaleza que
tengan periodos por debajo del día y las
primeras civilizaciones que empiezan a
fijar las horas lo que hacen es
subdividir la duración del día solar es
decir desde que sale el sol en el
hasta que se pone en el ocaso en 12
partes iguales y sus relojes de sol los
marcaban con 12 sus divisiones
claro pensaran por un momento que en
verano dado que el día solar duran más
que en invierno las obras que resultan
de hacer las 12 sus divisiones son
mayores en verano que en invierno por
tanto era una hora poco cómoda no era
una hora uniforme era una hora que no se
podía utilizar para por ejemplo como
unidad para medir la duración de eventos
y que hacían aquellos hombres cuando no
tenían el sol a la vista
pues bueno un día nublado por la noche
utilizaban relojes de agua que es lo que
hace un reloj de agua pues
fundamentalmente generar eventos
el evento era la gota de agua que pasa a
través de un orificio y acumular esos
eventos acumulada en estos eventos en un
recipiente en donde utilizaban
diferentes marcas dependiendo de la
época del año estos dispositivos
dependiendo del nivel de agua como
seguían estando calibrados por los
relojes de sol tenían necesariamente que
tener diferentes escalas dependiendo de
esa época del año
verán que en todo momento siguen mirando
el astro sol y el comportamiento
realmente de lo que ocurre con el ciclo
solar pero tiene que llegar el siglo 13
finales del siglo 13 y ocurre algo
importante en la concepción del tiempo
lo que viene a ocurrir es que hacemos
por primera vez relojes mecánicos en
donde básicamente ocurre lo mismo que en
el reloj de agua es decir hay una
generación de eventos dentro del
mecanismo del reloj y una
contabilización de esos picks que se van
generando en el reloj lo que ocurre es
que son tan sofisticados tan complejos
que ya no hay posibilidad de calibrar
los con el reloj de sol por tanto por
primera vez ocurre que necesariamente se
tiene que fijar una hora que valga
siempre lo mismo a lo largo de todo el
año ya no son esas horas que llamaban
los antiguos temporarias y que cambiaban
en verano o invierno sino que son horas
uniformes calculadas como la 24ava parte
de la duración promedio del día solar a
lo largo de todo el año
bien lo que ocurre entonces es que por
primera vez el tiempo es uniforme es
objetivo y es abstracto porque ya no hay
que mirar los eventos que ocurren fuera
ya no hay que mirar el sol ya no se
calibra con el sol lo que ocurre ahora
es que el evento existe aunque no lo
vemos está dentro del reloj
si a un antiguo griego le preguntáramos
que a qué hora es la puesta de sol
probablemente nos pondría cara de
incredulidad se sonrojaría miraría para
todos lados no sabría qué hacer y
finalmente contestaría pues a la hora de
la puesta de sol porque todo lo que
ocurría ocurría en torno a los ciclos
solares por primera vez como digo deja
de ser así en el siglo 13
en el siglo 17 llegan los relojes de
péndulo mucho más precisos en el pleno
siglo 20
llegamos a descubrir el fenómeno
piezoeléctrico y a partir de ahí surgen
los relojes de cuarzo hablo de 1930 y en
la segunda mitad del siglo 20 llegan los
relojes atómicos en sus diferentes
configuraciones y complicaciones hay
muchísimos modelos que siguen hasta
nuestro día
y cuál es la precisión de qué precisión
estamos hablando como en la mejora pues
miren si en un reloj de tipo mecánico
del siglo 14 resulta que éramos capaces
de mantener algunos minutos al día y de
hecho los primeros no tenían ni siquiera
minutero en el siglo 17 tres siglos
después conseguimos que los relojes de
péndulo mantengan varios segundos de
error al día hemos mejorado
aproximadamente en tres siglos en 30
veces la calidad del reloj con los
relojes de cuarzo hay un cambio bastante
más radical somos capaces de tener
dispositivos que mantienen el segundo en
1520 días por tanto mejora en
prácticamente dos siglos en 150 veces la
precisión de los relojes y a partir de
aquí viene
el avance impresionante los relojes
mecánicos promedio de la segunda mitad
del siglo 20 son capaces de mantener el
segundo en tres millones de años vemos
por tanto una evolución muy clara que
además se hace mucho más evidente en el
final del siglo 20 en la actualidad
somos capaces de ir mejorando la calidad
de los relojes en el ritmo de 10 veces
cada década cada diez años hasta el
punto de que somos capaces de hacer
ahora relojes atómicos de tipo óptico en
donde el segundo es capaz de mantenerse
durante 30 mil millones de años es una
cantidad semejante a la edad del
universo
y realmente es necesario todo este
progreso
a qué viene tanto afán por mejorar
porque esa ambición del hombre por tener
la medida cada vez mejor bueno pues la
respuesta es clara el progreso ha venido
en la medida en que ha habido una
demanda por parte de la sociedad
y efectivamente
la capacidad de medir ha supuesto
progreso tecnológico y ese progreso
tecnológico ha estado orientado a
asegurar la calidad de la vida de las
personas
y desde cuando esta concepción desde
cuando al servicio de la sociedad
pues ya desde el siglo 19 justamente con
las transformaciones económicas que
tiene el lugar durante plena revolución
industrial resulta que ya es necesario
concebir una hora dentro de las ciudades
y así se genera lo que se llamaron
horarios de carruajes eran horarios para
que los obreros pudieran llegar a la
hora a las empresas para trabajar
fíjense que por culpa de esto por
primera vez cada ciudad tenía su hora
era la hora solar del lugar hora solar
media del lugar
y en aquella época cada ciudad tenía su
hora de manera que por ejemplo cuando en
cádiz era las 12 de la mañana en madrid
hacía 10 minutos que habían pasado las
doce de la mañana y en barcelona algo
más de 30 minutos pero lo que de verdad
supone un cambio en la concepción del
tiempo
en la concepción social del tiempo tiene
que ver con la invención del tren con la
invención del tren es necesario unificar
horarios y horas porque hay que
coordinar los trayectos porque hay que
lograr eficiencia en el uso y en la
explotación del medio de transporte y
porque hay que asegurar la vida de las
personas evitando catástrofes por tanto
por primera vez hay que intentar poner
orden mucho más allá de la hora que se
tenía en cada ciudad llega en 1884 y se
produce un evento bastante importante en
la historia del tiempo
en aquel momento sigue creciendo todo lo
que tiene que ver con el transporte y
las comunicaciones y entonces se crea la
necesidad de tener una hora universal y
en una en una determinada asamblea
justamente en la conferencia del
meridiano de conferencia internacional
del meridiano en 1884 en washington se
determina que la referencia
internacional será una hora referida al
meridiano de greenwich además se adopta
el sistema de husos horarios
que básicamente consiste en que cada
país tendrá una hora legal u oficial que
es exactamente la del meridiano de
greenwich pero teniendo un desfase de
tiempo un número exacto de horas para
tener en cuenta la longitud o la
distancia a la que se encuentra ese país
del meridiano de greenwich
bien estamos en una situación
en la que en 1929 prácticamente la gran
mayoría de los países del mundo tienen
ya adoptada esa referencia horaria y
durante el siglo 20 ha habido una gran
evolución ya siempre hablando de escalas
internacionales
primero se definen escalas que son de
tipo dinámica definidas a partir de lo
que ocurre con la tierra y cuál es su
dinámica tanto rotación en torno a su
eje como traslación en torno al sol en
1972 por primera vez se define una
escala de tiempo tiempo universal
coordinado que será una escala hecha con
relojes atómicos aproximadamente 450
relojes atómicos distribuidos en unos 75
laboratorios por todo el mundo y es esta
escala precisamente tiempo universal
coordinado la que gobierna nuestras
vidas y que tenemos presente de una
manera constante y necesaria en nuestro
día a día
adivinan en qué situaciones podemos
encontrar ese tiempo en nuestras vidas
pues miren por ejemplo quien no utiliza
el receptor gps pues miren la distancia
de gps al receptor son distancias de
vuelo que efectuaron una onda
electromagnética por tanto si somos
capaces de medir los tiempos de vuelo
dado que esa onda se propaga la
velocidad de la luz podemos conocer
realmente cuál es la distancia a
continuación lo único que hay que hacer
es triangulación a partir de diferentes
distancias desde satélites al receptor
en el que me encuentro
si yo tengo un error del orden del nano
segundo el error en posición a la
velocidad de la luz será de 30
centímetros y esto explica y justifica
perfectamente la necesidad de medir con
tanta precisión algunos se preguntarán
qué es eso de un nanosegundo la mil
millonésima parte de un segundo un
nanosegundo es a un segundo lo que un
milímetro a la distancia de cádiz a la
coruña con lo cual puedes entender en
qué dimensiones están las medidas que se
hacen hablaba al principio del uso del
teléfono móvil o de los sistemas de
transferencia de datos necesitan tiempo
preciso para hacer un uso eficiente de
las frecuencias que ya de por si
utilizan bandas de frecuencias muy
limitadas para que los teléfonos se
puedan conectar entre sí qué decir de la
energía y de las compañías que se
dedican a distribuir oa transferir
energía es necesario tener tiempo
preciso y frecuencia precisos para que
esa energía se distribuya de manera
eficiente entre todos los los usuarios
sobre las empresas que hacen
transacciones de tipo comercial o la
propia banca de inversión que también
necesita hacer transacciones de tipo
financiero también está detrás el tiempo
preciso para poder en todo momento
seguir el comportamiento que han seguido
los registros que utilizan en las
transacciones que he citado
la propia administración pública
necesita igualmente tener tiempo preciso
en sus sistemas y aplicaciones para
aquellos servicios que prestan los
ciudadanos de manera telemática a través
de sistemas electrónicos quien no
recuerda el frustrado fichaje de la vida
gea en 2015
bueno pues aquello fue un problema de
tiempo fueron 30 minutos media hora pero
pudo ser perfectamente un segundo
realmente llegó fuera de plazo con lo
cual la que yo no pudo seguir adelante
en fin un largo etcétera que pasaría por
ejemplo por la regulación semafórica la
tele gestión del agua contadores de agua
contadores de luz sincronización de el
transporte público y un largo etcétera
como digo de elementos que aportan su
granito de arena lo que entendemos hoy
día como ciudad inteligente en donde lo
que se trata de buscar es la máxima
eficiencia y sostenimiento siempre
pensando en el confort de las personas
hemos llegado a un punto
muy alto en cuanto a logros
en lo que tiene que ver con avance
tecnológico y todo eso ha sido posible
gracias a que tenemos la posibilidad de
medir con precisión el tiempo hemos sido
capaces de generar ingenios que hacen
las medidas objetivas de manera uniforme
y aunque abstracta nos hemos ingeniado
la manera de controlar ese es ahora
abstracta para hacer un buen uso de esa
hora y todo esto al final ha incidido en
mejorar en nuestro día a día el progreso
y el bienestar de las personas
y si esto no hubiera sido así
en qué situación nos encontraríamos
bueno yo les invito a pensar por un
momento en lo que les voy a contar
imagínense un día en el que se levantan
de repente no tiene posibilidad de
encender los dispositivos electrónicos
ni televisión
y el teléfono móvil
necesitan
preparar la leche pero que no tiene
frigorífico tiene que tomar la leche del
día en cuanto al café hay que recurrir
al molinillo de mano
tenemos que preparar las tostadas y el
café en una cocina de butano resulta que
nos dirigimos al trabajo o al lugar de
estudio y no puedo el ascensor hay
que bajar por la escalera porque el
ascensor no funciona salimos a la calle
y todos los semáforos parpadean en ámbar
el caos circulatorio está asegurado
tenemos que tener cuidado porque no
sabemos por dónde andamos estoy seguro
de que no hace falta llegar hasta este
punto tan tan extremo probablemente si
yo les dijera que no pueden disponer a
partir de ahora del teléfono móvil
muchos de ustedes no lo soportarían
en definitiva
gracias a que hemos sido capaces de
medir el tiempo con precisión
hemos llegado por fin a una situación de
avance tecnológico
que nos ha permitido definitivamente
a que la humanidad pueda vivir mejor día
a día
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]